foreign
CJ is starting off this hour in Chicago
hi CJ how are you
hi thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's up
so um I'm 38 years old my wife's 34.
um we haven't uh our take-home income is
about 120 000 a year and
I've been well we've been working on um
paying off fifty seven thousand dollars
in debt
um for the last six months or so and my
wife she's six months pregnant
um
so I've just been kind of saving money
since we found out and come to find out
uh she racked up fifty thousand dollars
in credit card debt that I wasn't aware
of and I'm terrified and I don't know
what to do
in the last six months
um no this is actually been going on for
longer than that I think it got worse
since she became pregnant buying baby
stuff and I don't know what all has gone
through her head
um but
yeah I'm scared
okay let me let me make sure I get the
entire picture Okay
um she knew
and you two were having conversations
that you're trying to pay off fifty
seven thousand dollars in debt
yes and you're watching to do that
meantime she's buying things
and so she was lying to you
Yeah by not telling me she was lying
yeah wow purposefully hiding it that's
like deception
correct yeah terrified's probably not
the right word to describe your emotions
yeah that's that's accurate
um
when you okay confronted or what what
happened
um she immediately came clean and
started crying and she I mean she feels
bad about it she knows she was in the
wrong
um
I I told her that you know I can forgive
her if she picks Right Stuff
clean this up with me and I mean with
her being about to have a baby in a few
months I told her
um I will work as much overtime as I can
luckily it's available to me did she
tell you about it or you found out about
it and confronted her because that's a
key thing here yeah
parameter
how'd you find it
um I had someone call me wanting us to
um
for refinance our mortgage and they were
going through our credit report and when
he told me how much debt we had I told
him he was wrong because it was fifty
thousand dollars more than what I
thought we had
and then he went through and told me
what it was and
that's when I confront her and she came
clean all right so let me back out let
me pan out just a minute here okay and
then we'll get to what to do tactically
with the money stuff in a little while
okay having done what I do for 30 plus
years
um what we've discovered is is that uh
this is first and foremost a breach of
trust
right
the money is secondary
the primary thing and that's why people
in my world call this financial
infidelity
because it's a deep breach of trust
sexual infidelities are deep breach of
trust
and truthfully for most people this
activates the same part
in your brain or in your soul that
sexual infidelity activates because it's
first it's not sex as much as it is a
deep breach of trust
right right and so uh I'm telling you
all that and I'm making a big deal about
it not to get her in trouble but I'm
going to strongly suggest you guys see a
marriage counselor
right I think that's probably gonna
happen your wife systematically lied to
you for an extended period of time and
she needs to get that really deep inside
of her
she's been a liar a deceiver for an
extended period of time and what that
does to your relationship and what that
does to your trust of her this is not I
bought something at Target and forgot to
tell you
right this is a this is a way different
thing hey can I ask you a question fifty
thousand dollars is a lot of money which
means there's a lot of items was she can
can I just ask was she bringing home
things and you're like hey where did you
get this and she's lying oh it was a
gift did you notice things coming into
the house can can you tell me a little
bit how are you so unplugged the 50
Grand where the stuff shows up and you
don't realize it yeah well it's 100 I
mean I take full responsibility for not
noticing sooner
um yes she was buying you know baby
stuff but no like big ticket items are
really self any alarms
um but I think she was using it it just
became a crutch for us she was using it
for everyday items groceries she's
wondering for anything she wanted that
was not in the budget the two of you had
agreed to yeah
yes yeah whoo
so yeah you guys got some relational
work to do first and foremost okay and
the way a Henry Cloud's got a new book
coming out on trust if it's out already
you need to go get it and both of you
read it because the you were on track
the way you repair trust is first there
is a uh
uh an admission of how big a deal the
trust being broken is
by her and by you
to be honest with you the language
you're using is a little bit soft
pedaling it
you're not owning all of your emotions
in other words
I'm scared it's not like I'm really so
pissed off I can't breathe that's
different than I'm scared
yeah I don't think it's fully hit me
yeah like I said I just found out three
days ago so well I'm glad you're being
nice about it and behaving I don't want
you to do something crazier I mean that
but uh and I don't think this is the end
of your marriage it shouldn't be but she
has to own the fact that she has lied to
her husband
for an extended period of time that's a
big deal and then once she does that
then you say okay we're going to put in
place some systems and some
communication processes with the
guidance of our marriage counselor to
rebuild the trust
okay and that is going to be that we
talk a lot about this we talk a lot
about our budget we talk about a lot
about where every dollar is going we
talk about there's you know and you're
going to start pulling the Credit Bureau
report once a month
and um you know we're going to work
through this and pay it off together I
don't mind paying off the 50 Grand but
you've got to have Assurance deep in
your soul
that this is not going to happen or
something like this isn't going to
happen again yeah I'm wondering if
something set that off or was this a
behavior that you know
she's always just been prone to
overspending you know or is this
something that's like I'm freaking out
because I'm having a baby
you know what there's not really an
excuse there's
there's nothing there's a line I mean
it's just I don't having a lot of people
have babies
happens all the time uh lots of people
have husbands that are too tight on the
budget that's right wives that are too
tight on the budget and they still don't
have to lie that's true they just stand
up to the control freak and go uh-uh you
need a little more stuff for the baby
put it in the budget Bubba instead
sneaking off and running up 50 Grand is
not okay so you guys got to work through
the relational part of this and the
money stuff you'll clean up pretty quick
before we jump back to the calls let's
go uh back to that subject where a
spouse
has lied to their spouse over an
extended period of time about a large
amount of money yeah okay
um there's lots of possibilities of
things that go on there
um and so if you're out there listening
um and you're struggling with that let
me tell you the longer it goes on
the bigger the blow up when it comes out
so if you happen to tune in today you
need to go in
trust will be rebuilt faster if you
admit it rather than being discovered
yes number one so that starts the
process and then you need to figure out
what it was that caused you
to want to hide now what can happen is
and I've seen this a lot is it can be
this wasn't the case with that guy or
his wife but what can happen is one
spouse is doing the bills
the other spouse is just rocking along
yeah has no idea what's going on and the
spouse doing the bills can't figure it
out
it's out of control
and in order to keep up the lifestyle
that the other spouse that knows nothing
yes is going on they as a shame based
thing prop up the lifestyle with debt
yep and unbeknownst to the other spouse
so they're propping up the family
lifestyle
another thing that can happen is uh that
that causes this kind of deception most
the time these people are not just liars
yes they result in becoming Liars but
they're not like I get the opportunity
to with malice Screw Up My Life by lying
that's not usually what's going on in
their head so it can be shame based in
that regard another thing that can
happen is they start that you have a
spouse that is a control freak that's
too tight on the budget
and their way of rebelling
is to say well screw you right I'm just
going to go over and get some stuff like
you don't give us enough for food so I'm
gonna buy some food yeah I'm taking
matters into my own hands I can ring
this up on a credit card and that way I
they're trying to pull back some control
into their own hands yeah because the
the relationship isn't healthy right
meaning there's no give and take both
votes don't count at the budget
committee meeting so when you're having
a budget committee meeting both votes
count both of you get a say
and you know and and in case of a tie
you got to figure it out that's right
and so uh you're not you know yes I want
to get out of debt really fast yes we're
going to sell intents but no 100 a month
for a family of six is not enough for
food hello okay I mean really well then
there's the scary side of it Dave where
if there's a spouse that's pulled out
their own credit card and they're
spending there could be something even
more ominous at play whether it's an
affair or some sort of addiction problem
exactly that's that's the third one is
they're hiding some other misbehavior
with the financial so it's not unusual
at all I mean because the the thing we
used to laugh about it's not funny but
you know a guy's having an affair and
he's covering all of that with a credit
card over here hidden on the side
because you can't really put side honey
in the budget right right a light iron
item in the budget we're going to agree
to right right so uh that that you know
that's what you got to figure out so
that ain't you know that doesn't play
either but there's there so deception is
deception is deception and it can be
that there's something else going on
well the question is okay so we know
Dave
um in the case of gambling in the case
of addiction even some of those other
things those would be the times where
you can put limitations on how you're
combining your money exactly now what at
what point because the call we took
earlier there was fifty thousand dollars
being spent that's a lot of money at
what point would you say okay maybe it's
not addiction maybe it's not something
like that but my spouse is just gone off
the rails at what point would you say
okay there might be a separation of
finance that has to go into it there's a
separation of Finance until trust can be
rebuilt if trust can never be rebuilt
that means the marriage is gone yeah
agree I agree with you uh I mean if
you're dealing with someone who's
recovering uh from an addiction wouldn't
be unusual at all for them to have zero
access
to the money for a period of time and
full communication and openness yeah
because that's part of recovering from
the addiction is cutting off the supply
of money to do the addiction and so and
to continue to destroy the family in the
process so and violation of that money
thing is also an indication you're back
in the stuff you're back in the
addiction okay you're falling off the
wagon so uh folks that we don't do
Addiction Counseling here but folks that
do what we work with a lot and they tell
us all the time there's always a money
tie yeah it's always a money type you
cannot be an addict 100 of addicts
eventually have financial trouble well
yeah because something is funding this
no something yeah something's out of
control and it's always going to show up
in the checkbook and so that's what's
going on so there can be that there can
be just it could just be simple shame
yeah but whatever it is on your end if
you're the one that's doing the
deceiving a hundred percent of this
stuff is discovered event centrally
eventually it's going to come out that's
why it's so much better to just put it
out there look it's so much if you're on
the the negative side of this the
receiving end of it I would feel so much
better if someone came to me and said
here look I made a mistake here's what I
did as opposed to me randomly finding
out about it and having to come to you
and go here's what I found out right
there's a lit a Teensy bit more grace
when that person comes to you yeah well
and there and uh it's easier to begin to
trust again because that's a first
indication of owning it well yeah you
there's got to be some remorse there in
order for them to have done that yeah
right exactly